ونتابع اذا مع ما يظهر على شاشتنا من خبر
عاجل
ونشير لاحقا اذا الى هذه الاخبار العاجله
اذا المراسل الجزيره يتحدث عن سماع يدوي
انفجارات في بلده بيروت ومحيطها
والمصادر الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن اعتراض
صواريخ من غزه هذه التطورات بالتاكيد
ترافق خبر استشهاد الشهيد خضر عدنان بعد
اضرابه عن الطعام في السجون الاسرائيليه
ادت الى استشهاده هذا الصباح وما رافق
ايضا ذلك من ردود فعل فلسطينيه من
المقاومه الفلسطينيه على وجه التحديد ومن
السلطه الفلسطينيه ايضا
وفعاليات كثيره في الشوارع الفلسطينيه في
الضفه الغربيه وفي قطاع غزه مندده ورافضه
لما تنتهك يقوم به سلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي داخل السجون بحق الاسرى
الفلسطينيين ونشير ايضا الى ان مراسلنا
ضمن الاخبار العاجله التي تشاهدونها على
الشاشه الان يقول ان اطلاق عدد من القذائف
الصاروخيه من شمال قطاع غزه باتجاه
المستوطنات المحاذيه للقطاع اذا مراسلنا
من غزه ينقل عن اطلاق عدد من القذائف
الصاروخيه من قطاع غزه
وسماع دوي انفجارات في بلده سديروت
ومحيطها والمصادر الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن
اعتراض صواريخ من غزه طبعا الى جانب تلك
الصواريخ التي قال جيش الاحتلال انه جرى
اطلاقها من قطاع غزه صباح هذا اليوم وسقطت
بالقرب من النقب الغربي او في محيط النقب
الغربي تزامنا كما ذكرنا مع استشهاد
الاسير
عدنان في سجن الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اذن
المزيد من الاخبار العاجله ينقلها مراسلنا
الان تتحدث عن ان مدفعيه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تستهدف الان نقطه او نقطه رصد
تابعه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه شرق مدينه غزه
اذن مراسلنا ينقل ان مدفعيه الاحتلال
تستهدف نقطه رفض تابعه للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه شرق مدينه غزه وللمزيد ننتقل
الى غزه ومع مراسلنا من هناك وائل الدحدوح
والم الذي يجري
واضح ان جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ربما
اراد الرد على ما اعلن عنه صبيحه هذا
اليوم باطلاق ثلاثه قذائف هاون او قذائف
صاروخيه انطلاقا من قطاع غزه فاستهدف
واحده من نقاط الرصد المتقدمه المتاخمه
للسياج الفاصل وبالتحديد قباله مدينه غزه
شرق مدينه غزه استهدفها بقذيفتين مدفعتين
وهي عاده هناك عدد من نقاط الرصد المتقدمه
المنتشره على امتداد السياج الفاصل سواء
من الناحيه الشماليه او من الناحيه
الشرقيه وعاده ما تستهدف في كل مرات
التصعيد بالتاكيد المحدود وربما هذه المره
من ضمن هذه المرات التصعيديه جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي استهدف هذه النقطه وهي لا يوجد
بها اي عناصر للمقاومه باعتبار انهم انها
نقاط مخلاه في مثل هذا الاجواء المشحونه
والمتوتره
والتي يتوقع ان يكون هناك رد على عمليه
اغتيال خضر عدنان او الشيخ خضر عدنان
ولذلك هذه المدفعيه بالتاكيد احدثت اضرارا
في نقاط هامشيه وثانويه وصغيره جدا
يعني بعد ذلك مباشره كان هناك عمليه اطلاق
لعدد من الصواريخ شهود العيان تحدثوا عن
سماع عدم اطلاق عدد من الصواريخ باتجاه
المناطق او الاهداف الاسرائيليه القريبه
من قطاع غزه تحديدا في منطقه الغلاف
وبالتحديد اكثر في مناطق الشمال والشمال
الشرقي من من قطاع غزه
وحسب يعني حتى الان هناك صافرات انذار في
اكثر من منطقه حقيقه في مناطق الغلاف وهذا
يشير الى ان
الاطلاق يستهدف اكثر من نقطه اكثر من من
كيبوتس او مستوطنه في هذه المنطقه
بالتاكيد الموقف الان ربما دخل مرحله
جديده
نستطيع القول بان القصف المدفعي
الاسرائيلي والان اطلاق رشقات من الصواريخ
باتجاه الاهداف الاسرائيليه هذا يعني بان
مرحله جديده دخلت فيها الاجواء في قطاع
غزه لا ندري هل ستتسع الدائره وتتدحرج
باتجاه على سبيل المثال ان تطلق المقاومه
ربما رشقات جديده باتجاه اهداف ابعد ام ان
الامر سوف يتوقف عند هذا الحد اغلب الظن
بان الامر ربما ياخذ شكلا متدحرجا اكثر
لكن دون ان يصل الى يعني يعني انهيار شامل
او ربما موجات تصعيد كبيره جدا وما شابه
ذلك لكن كل هذا ياتي في سياق التحليل
والتنبؤ والتوقع لان الفصائل الفلسطينيه
هي الاخرى تتكتم على طبيعه الرد وكما
ذكرنا في مقابلات سابقه الفصائل
الفلسطينيه منذ ساعات الصباح وهي تدرس
امكانيه الرد او شكل الرد كيف هذا الرد
طبيعه الرد من اين سيكون الرد وواضح بان
هذه ربما واحده من القرارات التي اتخذت من
خلال الفصائل الفلسطينيه سوى في غرفه
العمليات المشتركه